I didn't know what to expect
aesthetically speaking I didn't know
like what your Vibe would be or oh well
what did you think it was going to be
what did you imagine I knew you had
horses which I was so excited I was like
could we ride and uh but I and you did
you wore boots I I wore boots for you I
love eclectic collected and homy you're
saying all the right things why do you
love horses so much because they're
beautiful and Powerful and kind and
generous there's so like much to say
about like I'm going take my hat off now
um there's so much to say about like
eoin therapy and how much people talk
about horses being so powerful to bring
you into these
new places that you need to go that
you're stuck and can't get to oh
completely no there's a lot of it really
does work
and I mean they're they're just this
very large powerful animal that allows
you to get close and personal in the
middle of the night I'll get up if I
can't sleep I'll go down to the Stalls
and I'll
just hug a horse really yeah I'll just
stand there and hug the horse or if the
horse is lying down sleeping I'll just
sit down on the floor and just hug them
on the floor so that's the gener like
they're so generous it's what'll let us
embrace them like that is so adorable do
you know how much I'm going to like live
with the visual now of you waking up in
the middle of the night and going to
your horses and you my husband wakes up
I'm gone I'm I'm I'm gone from the bed
Fred Fred my husband
Fred and when he finds me there I'm in
like a trance I'm just hugging I've I've
tried studying meditation throughout the
years and then my problem is like
consistency of practice but I have a
space I know it's available I've been
doing it a lot lately and it has been
really helping so I could meditate into
a horse and if you have any tools you
know the horse thing is is is a real
thing and so today we're going to when
to we get out there with them you're
going to think about you're going to
take in the scent I'm going to give you
some things to some um elements of
atmosphere to take with you when you're
thinking this when you're visioning this
I would love it I love that deep one of
the things that I try so hard to press
upon in this is like the trying to to
make it okay that we are not one thing
you know I didn't want to just be an
actress I wanted to be a producer writer
director I wanted to
um go into branding or try other things
but I I didn't want to just be one thing
and you started in country and crossed
over to rock and pop and were like genre
list and you were everything was that a
conscious break of that bubble or did it
happened by your continuance of just
being you and that was the result of it
I am all those
things just genuinely and you can't do
them you can't do everything all at once
so uh you know I I I do like to focus
and get the best out of one thing and
then move on to the next thing I'm I I'm
Restless I'm I'm I like to um shake
myself sometimes
uh jumping out of a plane is one of
those things that you know I know when I
needed to be shaken up a little bit you
know you just need to like okay come on
wake up I if I'm I and I can I overcome
the anger I how do you overcome anger a
lot of things are meditative I know
we're going back to this meditation
thing
but dreaming is my biggest meditation do
so when I'm when I'm somewhere bad I
just dream about things that I that I
can't have especially can because you
can't have everything that you dream
about which is fine and that's part of
letting go too is there something you
dream about that you can't have all the
time well I would have had more kids and
no regret but I dream about it so I
dream
oh this is the kind of parent I would I
I allow myself to go to go places that I
can't change but that I still love to
live in those mental spaces I dream
about things that aren't realistic and
then I just go there I literally go
there in my mind that's why it's
meditative when you took a 15year break
and Hiatus to take care of your own
health did you have any fear of what was
on the other side of that did you enjoy
it did you relax into
it I'm asking for personal
reasons well it goes It goes to one of
those things once I hit a wall a place
where I thought I couldn't ever change
it when I really was convinced by every
Medical Professional saying I mean
we don't know what's wrong with you and
we can't so we can't fix it we can't
determine what's wrong with you so why
you can't scream and yell and and and
and and control your your voice we don't
know
so I Then I then I did relax into it I I
wasn't complacent I wasn't giving up I
was in fact I was starting over yes with
new possibilities it was a real
Liberation I think that
that allowed me to appreciate the
songwriting more than ever I didn't have
to be the singer anymore I didn't have
to be in the spotlight anymore I can
write for other people to be in the
spotlight and and I know I really did
see it that way I I asked you because I
think it's such an important thing for
all of us to know and believe that
sometimes a door has to shut in order
for another one to open and instead of
being in fear of that is to be excited
exced about what that other door is this
is the thing you don't know what's next
you don't know if you're what what
what's around the corner you don't know
that I think it's very important for me
to live in that
reality I didn't know that I was ever
going to get my voice back again I
really didn't know yet so okay I I
grieved it and then you know science
opened the door and said we we do know
what's wrong with you and we they said
that door isn't closed yeah
exactly
[Music]